[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and how you can decompose a matrix X
into the product of three matrices u
Sigma and V transpose where u and V have
the very special property that they are
unitary matrices and Sigma is a diagonal
matrix so U and V being unitary matrices
essentially means that they only rotate
space they rotate vectors but they don't
change the angles between them or the
lengths of these vectors so U and V are
kind of analogous to other matrices like
the the Fourier transform Sigma can
stretch can stretch directions U and V
can only rotate them so I want to code
this up in that lab and show you kind of
how this actually works with the
geometric interpretation of this U and
this V space R and again all of the code
for this is at databook u-dub comm in
both matlab and python ok so let's get
started we're going to go to this code
this is from section 3 of chapter 1 of
the book and I'm not going to type this
all alive I'm mostly just gonna run this
and kind of walk you through in broad
brushstrokes what this is doing and then
show you how it's related to the SVD ok
so a lot of this is just to make the
plot look nice I got you know the fonts
larger and I've got some window where
I'm going to view these these matrices
and remember just as a recap what we're
doing is we're going to take the unit
sphere of vectors of unit length so
these vectors
I guess V of unit length in the unit
sphere and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna map them through this matrix X
we're gonna map them through this matrix
X X and we're going to get some kind of
an ellipsoid that's gonna stretch in
some directions and compress in other
directions ok so we walked through this
in kind of math in the last lecture now
we're gonna walk through this in code in
this lecture okay and so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna find
out how these various matrices can be
interpreted as rotations and stretching
through multiplication by this matrix X
and so I'm actually going to work
backwards what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a matrix that I know has
a rotation and stretching so I'm going
to build a matrix that rotates and
stretches this sphere and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to compute the
SVD of that matrix and show you that the
U and the Sigma matrices capture exactly
that rotation okay and I actually think
that this would be a fantastic place if
you want to do kind of a homework
exercise or like a mini project to make
sure you really understand this kind of
geometric connection of the SVD you can
work through exactly every step of how
these matrices relate to these different
transformations and you can play around
with the code you can see what the
inverse transformation does and and I
think that would be probably good for
all of us to do okay good so I guess
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
define this rotation matrix and I'm
gonna define it by rotating through X
rotating through the Y axis and then
rotating through the z axis according to
these rx ry and RZ matrices and each of
them is going to rotate a different
through a different angle about those
axes so theta 1 theta 2 and theta 3 are
going to be PI 15s minus PI ninths and
minus PI twentieths you can go back and
refresh yourself that this is in fact
the rotation matrix about the x-axis the
rotation matrix about the y-axis and the
rotation matrix about the z-axis notice
that X is fixed in this rotation matrix
and you're rotating the y and z
variables and similarly with these
rotation matrices and then we're also
going to build this Sigma matrix here
which is going to stretch three along
this principal axis it's going to keep
the ii axis
exactly equal it's going to multiply it
by exactly one and it's going to squash
the third principle axis by a factor of
two or down to 0.5 okay so we're
constructing this rotation matrix R and
in some sense that's your X matrix that
we're going to multiply by I'm just
calling it R because I know it's a
rotation and stretching
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
build it by first warping this warping
this ellipsoid into the sphere into an
ellipsoid so that's what multiplication
by Sigma does then I'm going to rotate
about X then I'm going to rotate about Y
and then I'm going to rotate about Z
okay and that's what this this matrix is
going to do and so if I go all the way
down here now again there's a lot of
plotting commands but in MATLAB there's
a nice command sphere which will create
a sphere with a certain number of points
defining the sphere and it'll give you a
set of points in XY and Z so kind of a
grid of XY and Z points then we'll
define the surface of the sphere I'm
gonna plot that surface as a surface
down here using this surf command again
more plotting stuff more plotting stuff
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to take and I'm going to rotate my so
I'm gonna draw on this some principal
axes kind of sticking out of each of
these principal directions and I'm going
to rotate those axes through this R
matrix and confirm that they actually
stick out at the right locations of this
ellipsoid okay and then I'm gonna plot
everything plot everything plot
everything and I think that's basically
the whole the whole script okay so so
far I haven't actually used the SVD at
all here let's just verify that this
actually looks like what it should look
like okay so this is kind of a cool plot
that shows my original sphere with the
the axes the principal axes XY and Z in
these these kind of white lines and then
mapping through this rotation matrix
again in the code it's called R but it
doesn't really matter what I call it
it's my X matrix then mapping through
this rotation matrix essentially what we
do is we stretch into an ellipsoid and
then we rotate about x y&z to get this
shape here and it's a little hard to see
but it is twice as long as it is wide
and it's half kind of as tall as it is
wide and and in long good okay so that's
that's the first thing now
guess if I wanted to I could show you
what this would look like if I didn't so
remember this our is I think it was our
z ry
our x and then Sigma the stretching
matrix so what I could do is I could
just get rid of all of these rotations
and show you that this thing just
stretches out in fact I think I'm gonna
do that let me do that now so what I
would do is I would basically just get
rid of all of these rx ry RZ and make
them the identity matrix the 3 by 3
identity our Z equals 3 by 3 identity
and I think what this will do if I
didn't mess anything up is that it will
stretch these out but keep them aligned
with the principal axes okay now it's a
little hard to see because the axes
themselves are a little wonky but now
what you can see is that what I've done
is I've taken the X direction and I've
stretched the X direction out that's
right it's stretched out here it's a
little backwards the Y direction doesn't
get changed at all and the Z direction
gets smushed so that's if I got rid of
all of those three matrices and only
kept the Sigma and now as I add these
rotations we're going to rotate about
the x axis the y axis and the z axis
okay good but I think what I want to
show you now is if you computed instead
so we constructed this R but let's say
that I didn't know that this R was a
rotation matrix that just someone
emailed you of matrix R and told you -
you know decompose it and interpret it
so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to take the SVD of this R matrix
so we're gonna say u s v equals SVD of
our good and what I claim is that
because this R matrix is it's
essentially just a left rotation matrix
this is kind of a unitary matrix times
the diagonal matrix times an identity
matrix on the right that this is U this
is Sigma and this is V transpose from
the
so this rotation matrix if I SVD it the
U matrix will be exactly this rotation
and the Sigma matrix will be exactly
kind of stretching along those principal
axes and the V matrix will be the
identity so what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to replace instead of this
this R matrix I'm going to replace it
with just u times Sigma and in principle
nothing should change that's how we can
kind of verify that this is in fact the
interpretation so u times Sigma I'm
gonna run the exact same code and I
should get the same kind of rotated
deformed rotated and deformed ellipsoid
and in fact you do okay so this is
exactly the same rotated deformed
ellipsoid that we saw earlier when we
mapped through R and now we're just
mapping through u and Sigma so nothing
was changed if you're really being
careful you'll notice that the color
flipped okay so this has kind of blue on
top and yellow on bottom and before our
matrix had blue on top and yellow on
bottom but now our lip side is flipped
and that's because this SVD is unique
and it does exist but it's only unique
up to sign changes in the columns of U
and V so what it looks like here is
maybe the Z or the third column of you
got multiplied by negative one got
flipped and this third column of V it's
not actually the identity it's maybe one
one negative one or something like that
I'm a little nervous about trying this
live to verify but we're gonna try it
okay so it turns out two of the
variables got flipped but it's
essentially an identity except that two
of the variables signs got flipped and
that means the two of the signs of the
columns of U got flipped but aside from
those sign changes which really don't
matter that much
this SVD is unique and it is capturing
that u matrix is capturing the rotation
of that matrix and the Sigma matrix is
capturing how much that matrix is
stretching okay so I find this to be
very useful to kind of have this
geometric interpretation in terms of
what these unitary matrices and and
singular values actually do to data okay
thank you